thank you for taking a break from
Starfield to watch this video by the way
Indiana Jones and the dial of Destiny
begins in a flashback at the end of
World War II where India's hunting down
artifacts that the Nazis have and he's
also been captured from here the movie
starts pretty quickly in terms of
thrusting us into a ridiculous scene in
which Indiana Jones miraculously
survives being hanged while also having
a bomb go off in the tower that causes
him to fling all over the place so
before going into all of that craziness
why are the Nazis even bothering about
going through all of this trouble and
killing Indiana Jones they're literally
staring at him with guns but they decide
to go all the way to the top of this
Tower and then set up a rope to hang
their prisoner why not just take him out
back and execute him with bullets
especially given that the entire
compound is evacuating with some haste
but this is obviously done so that
Indiana has some chance to escape in the
means in which he escapes is just so
baffling that the movie is already off
to a rough start surely this won't be
the only extreme convenience that
happens after getting out of the tower
Indiana Jones steals a car and knocks
out the driver with his iconic one punch
KO this is a movie stereotype but I'll
accept it the more annoying aspect to me
is that India is literally doing this in
the middle of a courtyard in full view
of dozens of people then some officers
get in the car and don't even question
the fact about why there's a passed out
Soldier right next to the driver's seat
or they're even being a motorcycle right
behind the car he's hijacking that
definitely would have saw someone get
tossed out of the vehicle so work two
for two already and it only gets worse
from here Indy eventually goes off
course to chase after the train in which
the artifact he's after is on so he has
to take out some bikers and ends up
hijacking one of them as they drive into
the forest now to say that Indie is
extremely lucky in this scene would be
an understatement because they somehow
don't hit a single tree despite not
looking at where they're going he
literally has the luck of domino from
Deadpool 2 in this movie so far not to
mention that he he's actively fighting
someone over control of the bike so for
sure dumb luck Indiana Jones gets onto
the train and does all the devoid of
logic nonsense finally stop here of
course it doesn't Indy saves his friend
baz and while they're running away from
the Nazis down the train some planes
bomb the anti-air gun now everything up
until this point was pretty lucky but to
me this takes the cake as being the
luckiest so the anti-air gun doesn't
actually get fully destroyed and
perfectly spins around right to the
exact angle to where it shoots out the
Nazis pursuing Indie and the train just
so happens to be going through a turn so
that the AI gun is firing at the enemy
and not the heroes this so conveniently
ends up essentially wiping out all the
Nazis chasing them and if the writer's
writing this moment think this was good
by any means and they're delusional we
want to see our heroes overcome major
conflict without the will of God solving
it for them so since most of the Nazis
on the train are dead now it allows the
more prominent villain to have a a fight
with Indy however what immediately
doesn't make any sense is why the
villain doesn't have a gun that he
simply shoots Indie with he literally
had one five minutes prior while
questioning baz and for some reason he
opts to use the artifact as a weapon
what a nice guy giving his opponent a
better Advantage but wait he actually
does have his gun and he doesn't use it
and Indiana Jones steals it while
they're wrestling it gets knocked away
and now baz has the gun instead of
chasing after the gun the villain simply
allows himself to be shot by baz with
virtually no protest you'd think someone
pointing a gun at you would be more of
an imminent threat than a guy with a
whip but whatever then Dr voller who's
the main villain scientist feels left
out so he also decides to join them on
the roof since he's after the
anti-gaithera at least he isn't dumb
enough to not initiate their
confrontation with a gun Indy hands it
over to him and then while on the side
of the train Dr voller gets bonked on
the head by a metal pipe now what do you
think happens from this point does voler
a flat I'll die in the spot from Pure
blunt force trauma B does he become a
vegetable from his brain getting so
destroyed or C does he simply get a
small scar in his forehead with no clear
mental impairments hey he picked a
depressingly obvious answer that is C
the writers basically make Dr voller an
impenetrable superhero for being able to
survive this the train was moving at
probably about 40-ish miles per hour and
he got struck in the head by a metal
pipe if I were to just fall down on the
ground and slam my head into concrete
I'd probably have to go to the hospital
let alone getting slammed in the head by
a pipe at high speeds the man should
have been decapitated at that force and
speed if anyone has seen hereditary then
you know what's up so yeah the prologue
for this movie feels like I'm watching
The Adventures of Tintin instead of an
Indiana Jones movie from how crazy and
absurd all the action set pieces have
been so far going to present day baza's
daughter Helena finds a good friends to
Indy and they talk about the
antichythera it turns out that she's not
an actual good person and is someone who
sells prized artifacts on the black
market which is what she intends to do
with the antichythera it also turns out
that voller is alive and is pursuing
Helena along with the US government
agents cooperating with him given that
he helped the U.S land on the moon
valder also has his own goons who are
much more loyal to him but are also very
sloppy because while in pursuit of
Indian Helena they murder two upstanding
civilians In Cold Blood which right away
is pretty insane that the government
agents wouldn't have immediately cut all
ties and have arrested them on the spot
I'm pretty sure some random chicks
selling stolen goods isn't as important
as killing two civilians but I don't
know what the writers are smoking so a
Chase initiates and Helena screws over
Indy by leaving him behind by locking a
gate this seems unnecessarily cruel
given that he's her Godfather and she's
essentially handing him over to the
wolves like he's on her side and I don't
know why she needed to betray him here
I'll go more into the subject later on
and how it impacts our character Arc and
her relationship with Indy throughout
the movie but because of this Indy gets
captured and has to escape the bad guys
which I'm not entirely sure why they
even need him since Fuller already knows
where the auction for the dial is going
to be held they're literally just
kidnapping this teacher for no apparent
reason other than he briefly interacted
with Helena for all they know she just
stole that Relic from him given that she
visually betrayed him but yeah he ends
up getting away by physically besting
his opponents now let that sink in for a
second Harrison Ford is 80 years old and
he has enough strength to overcome these
muscular brutes in their Prime along
with him being able to run away from
them like they should easily be able to
catch up but I guess they can't so Indie
hijacks a horse from a cop that
disappears and a Chase initiates Indy
ends up conveniently escaping in the
Subways in which he luckily doesn't get
decimated by trains and has perfect
timing when it comes to getting into one
still not sure why the bad guys want him
so badly but hey we wouldn't have an
action scene so don't question that I
feel like this would inherently be a
better action scene if it was done via
Helena escaping these bad guys given
that she's much younger and would be
more believable instead they make it to
where she quickly gets away moving on
Indiana Jones Is Now wanted for murder
since the police somehow came to the
conclusion that Indy was probably the
one to kill his colleagues I guess he
really didn't like that retirement gift
so now Indy is a wanted man and they are
publicly showing his face on the news so
since he's in a pinch he calls his
friend Salah to taxi him to the airport
I'm not really sure why that was
necessary and why he didn't just call a
normal cab this character's return
because of this doesn't really have much
of a point and feels more like a lazy
attempt to Garner Nostalgia from the
audience if you'd think it's because
Indy's popular now from his face being
all over the news it needs to be more
Incognito then that would make sense but
that's immediately contradicted by going
through an airport without being
recognized I know back in the day
airport security was light but surely
there are probably some police present
especially since there's a murderer on
the loose I feel like that would be an
absolute given to upgrade Security in
the area Indiana Jones simply just gets
on his plane and goes to Morocco in
which the auction for the anti-gythera
is being held also while on the plane
there's this whole flashback of Indiana
Jones taking the antichythera from baz
and has a brief encounter with Helena
however this exact moment was discussed
between Indian Helena so it feels
completely unnecessary to include this
this also especially feels worse given
that the movie is almost three hours
long so having to sit through what
should have been a deleted scene is
rough moving on to the next action set
piece Indy shows up to the auction
unannounced and crashes the party a
fight for the dial inevitably ensues and
at some point the dial flies into Indy's
hands when it does there's this brief
moment in which Indy punches a bad guy
and he goes flying which I find
hilarious that these guns are packing
that much power now this particular shot
of Indy with his whip facing an
onslaught of Guns is inherently really
silly I remember this being one of the
main shots in the trailer but I was
always like how the hell would Indy
realistically get out of that situation
and realistically he can't because the
bad guys just comedically shoot at
nothing Ollie Ducks under the table and
they don't bother shooting under it
after this Teddy steals the dial and
then runs right into Valor who steals it
in return how convenient voller then
takes the doll into a car with his goons
and they drive off Indian Helena would
pursue them but they are stopped by a
mob boss that Helena married for bail
money and obviously used he's very upset
with her and is essentially threatening
her and yet Andy comes in like a child
complaining to his teacher that Helena
stole his candy the item she's talking
about actually belongs to me
like why would he care you are barging
into this conversation and disrupting a
mob boss in any real World scenario the
mob boss would simply kill the person
disrespecting him like that but this
comes across as such a childish script
So eventually Helena upsets the mob guy
and they are now being chased by them
during this whole chase scene I find it
really admirable that Harrison Ford is
running around given his age but at no
point do I ever buy the fact that he's
able to outrun anyone or should be able
to keep up with Helena he's basically
hobbling around they eventually steal a
vehicle and get chased around the beds
and then through divine intervention
from the script writer gods they
randomly run into Dr voller now this may
not seem like that big of a deal from
watching this video however so much time
has passed since he drove off that there
is no possible way that they were able
to catch up to him or let alone find him
so this is obviously a crazy coincidence
and is a contrived way for the heroes to
fight the bad guys not only does this
happen once it actually happens twice
because they go off on another side
tangent of getting chased by the
Mobsters this entire scene is just so
nauseating in terms of where all these
characters are in relation to each other
and it's as if they are teleporting
around wherever the writers need them to
be without following any logic also
during this whole Chase let me show you
this moment
foreign
do you think the vehicle they are in
tumbles down the stairwell and they all
die or do they conveniently survive
without any injuries the fact that you
instinctively pick the second option is
very worrying for the writing and how
they present this ridiculous action it's
also pretty crazy that they are able to
come to a full stop after rocketing down
the stairwell and don't explode into the
wall at the bottom what's even more
ridiculous is that the vehicle is fine
and is still able to drive after this
but yeah from here it's just a circus of
devoid of logic Antics that again makes
this movie feel like Adventures of
Tintin in any grounded and realistic
action from the first few movies are
non-existent so the bad guys get away
and overthrow their U.S Associates
apparently the final blow for the US
agents was getting arrested in a foreign
country and not killing U.S civilians
going over to Indiana and Helena they
have some riveting discussions like this
it's kind of annoying that the writers
are making their interactions this
Juvenile and so far we are basically
halfway through the movie and they are
insufferable they finally decide to work
together after Indy practically begs to
tag along and they meet up with Antonio
Banderas pretty convenient that he knows
a diver in the exact area they need to
dive in but whatever between everything
that's happened that's the one thing
I'll buy while on the boats Indy
eventually tells Helena that his son who
was played by Shia LaBeouf died in the
military at the very least the writers
acknowledge that the character existed
but it still stings that they
nonchalantly kill his character
off-screen also this scene in terms of
dialogue lacks subtlety since Indie lays
out everything to a character he isn't
even getting along with the characters
dive down and get the next piece of the
puzzle that they are chasing after and
valer shows up and hijacks the ship they
arrive while they are diving which is
insane timing given that they were only
going to be down there for three minutes
so that's a contrived way to give
control over to the villains since our
heroes weren't present they also cut one
of the lines to oxygen for one of the
divers and luckily it wasn't an
important character I also don't
understand why this random NPC didn't
just activate his life vest and simply
rise to the surface after losing air
instead he chokes to death and falls
into the abyss and dies within seconds
surely he would have been able to hold
his breath a little longer since these
are divers but hey don't think about
that
things move forward Dr Jones and
sometimes
they go backwards get it because of time
travel so voller steals the graphicos
tablet which will Point them to the
final piece of the antichythera and ask
Andy to decipher it Indy In This Moment
makes the decision to not give in and by
doing so I guess he's all right with
having all of his friends be murdered
because of this Antonio Banderas is
deleted out of the movie and it just
feels so odd to have him be in the movie
if he's only going to be given like five
lines in response to this Andy makes a
cute attempt to try and Tackle this Hulk
of a human and obviously fails what were
you expecting you're 80 years old man
since Indy doesn't want to decipher the
tablet and we've run out of background
characters to kill Helena steps up to
the plate and asks for compensation not
sure why she waited for someone to be
killed and at this point I assume she's
a flat-out sociopath also voller has
complete Authority in this situation and
is threatening them so him agreeing to
hand over a hundred grand to Helena is
pretty surprising all he has to do is
threaten to kill her kid companion and
she'll immediately cave while
deciphering the tablet she shows Indy
that she has a stick of dynamite that
was glaringly set up earlier even though
it didn't show her grab any the shot
directly after this in which he turns
around and is greeted to the Hulk
looming over her is pretty funny though
this guy is literally staring down at
her and didn't even notice her pull
something out of her pocket to show Indy
surely he had line of sight but I guess
he's just zoned out even after this the
blocking of the scene assumes that you
forget these two goons in the corner are
even there because Helena is letting the
stick of dynamite within full view of
them even when she does light it they
aren't even active within the scene and
don't immediately capture Indian Helena
they're just standing in the corners if
the director put them in timeouts so
since they evaporated from the scene the
director created a contrived sense of
believability for them to escape I also
love how Indie won getting into the boat
doesn't even bother to take cover when
getting shot at his plot armor is so
thick that bullets don't scare him
anymore from here Indy sets The Wooden
Boat on fire like a mad lad in reveal
feels a golden dial underneath the
tablet the fact that he then picks it up
immediately is pretty insane given how
hot it should be now we're in Sicily
since this is where the next half of the
antichythera is located wow here Teddy
has an integral scene of eating ice
cream and by completing utter fate he
stumbles across the bad guys chilling on
the docks I find it funny how one of the
goons menacingly walks out of the
Shadows like Batman as if he's been
waiting for Teddy to fall into his trap
the scene gives off the same energy as
euron Greyjoy swimming ashore right when
Jaime passes through then since Teddy
has gone missing Indie picks a random
place to check on his whereabouts and
hey he just so happens to witness how to
get kidnapped it's only as if this is a
big city and today could literally be
anywhere yet another contrivance to give
Indy the confirmation that Teddy has
been kidnapped so now Indian Helena need
to steal a car which like the opening is
extremely easy since the awareness of
these background actors is non-existent
Indy simply walks up to the car opens it
and drives off and by the time he saw
starts the engine that's when these
people notice not when you know they
slam the door shut out of all the ways
to steal a vehicle I don't know why it
needs to be this devoid of logic while
on the way there Indy says this they're
not gonna hurt him
use it how would you even know their
goddamn Nazis have been proven in the
past to be extremely ruthless and
they've already killed a bunch of people
but they draw the line at kids arriving
at the team of Archimedes Indian Helena
somehow get there before valer despite
them being behind by this point since
there have been so many dumb aspects
bombarding the viewer they are probably
so numb to it that they don't even
question this moment from here this is
really the only solid portion of the
movie I didn't hate since it includes
some fun tomb raiding although it still
has some hard to believe aspects in the
script like this area barely being
explored despite it being a popular
location this light revealing the way to
go while the sun clearly isn't visible
anymore Teddy escaping the Bad Guys by
forcing him and his captor into the
river that has a convenient kid-sized
hole for him to escape and indy being
able to rock climb given his Stellar
physical condition I do give the movie
some bonus points for this funny rant
that Indie goes on though crumbling
vertebrae played in one leg through the
other inevitably the bad guys catch up
to Andy and Helena and Teddy also found
his way into the tomb even though he was
Swept Away in a river I'm kind of just
quickly touching on these really dumb
aspects when in reality these are major
deals they're becoming so numerous to
the point that I'm becoming desensitized
to the stupidity in this movie so Teddy
is up on this big slab of rock and
Helena spots him while the bad guys
behind her who have a better view of the
whole room somehow don't also like the
boat scene these background bad guys
won't do anything when the action pops
off because if they were actually active
they'd easily be able to kill the good
guys since they're right behind them so
after some brief action Indie tells
Helena and Teddy to get out of there and
India is now captured for whatever
baffling reason the Nazis don't quickly
pursue after Helena and Teddy and
capture them as well but if that were
the case the movie would instantly end
also Indy's plot armor is starting to
get unbearably thick since voller
suddenly wants to keep India alive I
don't know why this is the case since
they have no relationship or dynamic
given how fast their past encounters
have been they've basically have had
barely any back and forth dialogue
throughout the movie and the writers
expect us to buy the fact that vulner
wants to keep him around to witness his
victory like why would he even care so
now through yet another contrivance Indy
gets a front row seat to watch the
climax of the movie Helena and Teddy
catch up to the Nazis as they are
boarding their plane and Helena manages
to narrowly climb through the landing
gear before it takes off for Teddy he
hijacks a plane that's conveniently
ready to take off and is able to get the
plane into the sky this may seem wild
but at the bare minimum the movie Set up
an infatuation he has with planes so
this is finally one of the least dumb
aspects so far however the main question
is going to be how this kid will land
the plane successfully will he a somehow
land the plane like a pro B crash the
plane and walk away with no injuries or
C there's a pilot randomly sleeping
behind him who lands the plane for him
and the answer is C what a miracle that
this pilot is here or the story
physically won't be able to operate I
feel like that's what this movie has
been so far it surrenders connecting all
these idiotic aspects with duct tape and
hoping it functions in any way moving on
to the fun bit we have the actual time
travel portion of the movie now even
after watching the movie twice I still
don't understand how this dial is able
to get someone to a precise place and
time in the past but yeah between
everything in the movie I'll just buy
that time travel exists and instead of
going back to Germany they are
teleported to the siege of Syracuse in
214 BC this is where the movie finally
gains a small ounce of fun as everyone
freaks out about being sent to the past
the most hilarious moment during the
scene was when one of the Nazis opens
fire on the Romans when this happened I
bursted out laughing in the theater from
how ludicrously ridiculous it was I just
don't know what he was trying to achieve
here that's not going to do anything So
eventually when flying around they
slowly get brought down by numerous
scorpion bolts and don't pay any
attention to the fact that the plain
Teddy is on hasn't been hit it may be
smaller but given that they are getting
spammed by scorpion shots it's pretty
lucky that they're unscathed just before
the plane crashes Andy and Helena jump
out with the only parachute and share it
together as they float down to the
ground they're greeted by Archimedes who
brings them back the anti-keythera that
a conveniently found from the crash
sites so out of all the devoid of logic
aspects the movie surprisingly makes
sense from a time travel perspective and
doesn't make a glaring Paradox although
partially but it's whatever during the
scene Indy wants to stay behind since
he's still shot and is slowly dying
pretty irresponsible of him honestly in
terms of how you'll change the future
but this is actually a pretty emotional
scene and Harrison Ford did an excellent
job here he delivers a lot of sincerity
and you can really feel the amount of
care and love he has for the character
it does feel a bit weird in the moment
since you're alike are they actually
going to kill another beloved character
like Han Solo but luckily they don't
commit to to that and Helena knocks his
ass out on one hand I like this reversal
in having Indy get one punch ko'd but on
the other hand the man is 80 years old
and this would probably be a death
sentence for the guy given that getting
a concussion at that age probably isn't
the best so since he gets knocked out we
hard cut back to Indy's apartment and
everything is resolved that feels a
little cheap but since the movie is
already creeping up on the mid to hour
mark I'll take that as the Director
doing as a solid now taking a look at
Helena's character I personally think
that her Arc here and that she cares
deeply about Andy and desperately wants
to save his life is unearned especially
from an emotional standpoint because
she's left him to die on multiple
occasions and they only had a few brief
scenes of bonding so her drastically
changing and suddenly not caring about
money anymore doesn't feel like it was
properly built up too I like this Arc in
theory but the writers butchered her
character by making her so cold and
heartless for half the movie so yeah now
Indy teleported back to his apartment
and we get a happily ever after with his
wife returning just forget about the
fact that he's still a wanted man for
allegedly murdering his colleagues and
that's Indiana Jones in the dial of
Destiny it's pretty sad that this movie
ended up having such a dumb and juvenile
script and I was wishing for something
that was still fun while not
disregarding logic in every second of
the film since the first few Indiana
Jones movies were still grounded in
logic besides Crystal's skull that movie
also deserves to be stored away and be
forgotten about thank you for watching
and let me know in the comments what you
thought about the dial of Destiny and
follow me on letterbox for more reviews
on movies
thank you